you said already but just to be clear so
with this play in yeah people are fans
of France they will enjoy this play they
won't come to it thinking oh it's
friend's life and then gotta go what the
hell was that
no I don't think so I think it's a I
think it's a good play for the friends
generation and think it's a dark comedy
it's a little darker than friends was
but we're all older we're all eyes on
dark right yeah I mean it is so weird
even in the papers this week you know 12
years after friends yeah stop it's now
in the papers all this week because
there's a rumored reunion that you're
getting together yes is that true or no
no that's not true
because you'll be here well you I'm
gonna be here yes that it's not the
French reunion that everybody's hoping
for it's their celebrating Jim Burroughs
who was a director of friends and the
five of them are going to be on this
special and I'm going to introduce them
from here because I doing the play here
so I can't be there it's a really good
excuse as well as yeah yeah thanks well
is it it probably won't be a reunion
maybe they will but like so many big
hits friends lives on in its porn parody
yeah it's very true I think it maybe
it's even more than one porn party it's
it's very pop well there's one that I'm
familiar with I've got one here is your
that one what does that called friends
at xxx parody no the one I know about is
called fiends and in it all the
characters are having sex with each
other except for Chandler who's just
sitting in the corner masturbating
GEMA you're a fan would you like a copy
Oh beans this sounds quite good though
listen to this the comedy flies as do
the bodily fluids hilarity and deep
penetration ensues we have a condor it's
silly oh no it's not outfits covering
our I think you should have this
actually I made my own videos being in a
lot of form oh really I didn't realize
audio though only the audience yes I
hope you Evan
I've never actually done it in front of
a camera but you make the sounds of
making the sounds and I'm not doing it
now no I'm going to ask you brought it
up Miriam watch your show all right I
don't think anybody really wants this no
no we don't care people have this notion
if we don't if we leave it there
by the end of the show that'll be gone
and the guy at my travel on came back
from the bathroom or my friend said
that's not my match on the line what is
the name of Chandler's father's all-male
burlesque
I actually know that - that's Viva Las
Vegas